pens down eyes up you guys know how I
love starting off a lesson with a
picture you know how I really like
pictures so um I tried to outdo myself
today I have more than one picture for
you actually have several I'm gonna
start with me press the red button there
I'm gonna start with this one now can
anyone tell what is this this is the
inside of a submarine and this guy is
looking through a particular object our
periscope thank you very much I even put
the other end of it so it's a little
more obvious okay a periscopes job is to
see around things right in this case
like the rest of the submarine and the
water that's in the way that's what a
periscope does it sees around things
okay this image probably less familiar
but I've got some words here to help you
out right every human being has a
nervous system a nervous system that's
how you sense things around you you've
got the brain spinal cord and that's
what they call the central nervous
systems right they're literally in the
middle but then do you notice you know
if you just take your hand like pick it
can you poke it for a second you can
feel that right and you can feel that
would ya maybe don't do it too hard okay
you've got nerves there in your hand and
your fingers as well
you've got nerves all the way through
the rest of your body and they're not in
the center and that's why we call them
there just can't read that is it a big
thing it's the peripheral nervous system
okay in other words it's not at the
center it's all of the nerves you've got
around the rest of your body
okay so periscope peripheral you didn't
know any other words that start with
Perry hmm I went to look this up on
Google and I found this which was not
helpful I was like that's that's that's
not what I mean
okay I want you to think about these two
these are the ones I really mean right a
periscope sees around things when
something is peripheral it's around the
edges of it you can even talk about
peripheral vision for instance my
peripheral vision is awful
because I wear glasses and everything
outside of my glasses I can't see very
well okay so I want you to think is
there a mathematical word you know that
starts off the same way Harrison
perimeter thank you very much that's the
heading but I would like you all to make
perimeter
I wonder how quickly you worked out it
was and I was going to talk about that
perimeter now if a periscope is about
seeing around something and peripheral
like the peripheral nervous system is
the nervous system around the edges of
our body what would you guess perimeter
means yeah no very good it's kind of
like this is around right and if you
measure that's what meta means measure
around then what you've got is the
length outside of the shape right so
perimeter literally means not all words
are like this some words are really like
like peri-peri what a minute I don't
know what that means maybe in another
language but perimeter thankfully means
exactly what it says it's equal to what
it is is the length that you measure
around a shape or on the outside if you
like on the outside now I'm gonna sort
of scoop past most of the basics about
this because you've had a look at this
last yeah in u7 and even in primary
school you had a look at the idea of
perimeter can you draw a shape for me
please on your page any shape you like
may be about the size of you let's go
like half of your palm okay and I'm
really gonna make it any shape you want
triangle rectangle I am going to advise
that you have something with straight
edges a polygon because this is just
gonna be easier for you in a second and
if you have if you drew a circle
good job line if you have a ruler please
get it out if you don't have a ruler
mrs. Lee's already has read my mind so
just shoot your hand up and she'll bring
one round and I would love you to
measure the perimeter of the shape that
you draw can you do that measure the
perimeter of the shape that should draw
okay now I'll let you draw any shape
that you like triangle Pentagon hexagon
whatever you want but with that rule or
what I'd love you to do is can you
please get your physical mirror ruler
out measure each length and as you can
see what I've done is I measured each
one and then I labeled the length of
that side
on the side itself okay those of you who
drew triangles for yourselves are gonna
be like yes I have less things to
measure but that doesn't make it
necessarily easier if you've got a
square if you've got a rectangle or a
trapezium measure the lengths and then
for your particular shape I want us to
write down the bottom right perimeter
equals and then what I'd like you to do
is to say to yourself well I've measured
all of them and if preeminent perimeter
means the length that goes all the way
around the outside of the shape what am
I gonna have to do to in my case I got a
quadrilateral am I gonna do my four
numbers you go ahead thank you very much
I'm gonna add this this this and this
and I'd love you to write that down as
well write the actual numbers and not
just the answer and then we'll calculate
it in a second but of course we're all
gonna have something slightly different
oh can I do this in my head where you
reckon 3950 966
111 what do you think someone with the
cat codes can tell me if I'm right or
not I don't know okay you wanna check me
out LaVon you got much smaller shapes
obviously okay so what I love you have
is your shape your shape is it
yeah I can still do arithmetic okay you
want to have your shape all of your
measurements then I'd love you to write
perimeter equals and then show me your
measurements all adding up together
because that's the essence behind
perimeter okay all right now I just want
to give you two quick notes because
again you've seen perimeter before but I
just want to remind you of two
particular things to watch out for I'm
gonna get another color and I'd love you
to jot them down underneath or around
your diagram okay firstly perimeter it
needs to have all the lengths on the
outside
it needs to have all the links on the
outside actually I should written that
suit because otherwise we don't have the
entire perimeter now that means
sometimes if for example you don't have
all the lengths and why don't you just
to add all the numbers that you can see
to have the perimeter you really need
every single number then you're going to
encounter some questions where they
don't provide you every single length
you have to work some of them out using
some of your knowledge of the properties
of a shape maybe you're going to have to
use Pythagoras you remember that
right-angled triangles so you need all
the lengths but also importantly can you
watch this for a second just watch you
don't necessarily need every single
number that's written on the diagram for
instance suppose I just decided because
I wanted to to measure this diagonal it
looks about 35 centimeters to me okay
now you might see a diagram and it's got
all kinds of numbers on it and
perimeters like oh I want all the
lengths and then you add up 35 along
with your other ones
why is there no reason to add up to 35
yeah here very good it's from the
definition right just because the
numbers there doesn't mean you have to
add it so you want to look carefully at
the lengths they provide you and don't
just blindly add everything so that was
the first thing about all the lengths
I've got one other thing and hopefully
you put this on your diagram like I did
a mine near the color and that's units
now what you know have you chosen to
measure yours in yep
have you done said has anyone done
anything other than centimeters anyone
move all bombers centimeters maybe
because of the size of the ruler that we
have but you're going to see objects
which have all different kinds of
measurements not just centimeters what
else might they see meters what else
millimeters bigger kilometers okay if
they want to be really old-fashioned
they could throw inches and feet at you
okay now this is important so just make
a little note for units
I'll put it here on the side here okay I
want to say two things about units
number one watch out they might be
different because for instance let's
have a look at the one that I've drawn
up here on the board
I wrote 224 centimeters here but I
didn't have to I could have just
easily of written what would that be in
millimeters 240 millimeters that would
still be the length of that side but of
course if I went to my calculator and I
added 15 45 27 and 240 then I'm not
gonna get the right answer
am i because I've mixed up my units so
watch out that you there are the same
sometimes you might need to change them
just like Marik did with his decimal
Matis fraction I mean the last thing is
please include them can you have a look
at my answer up here on the board and
notice how I've written the units in
here right had I written my final line
is just a hundred and eleven that isn't
the perimeter because it could be a
hundred and eleven kilometers or 111
millimeters the units are really
important so please make sure not only
do you watch out for them but actually
include them okay so we said something
out all the lengths we said something
out the units I think you can't have a
go of this unless you have questions
yep so that's a great question but can I
get I want to look up for a second
because that was such an important
question I want everyone to make sure
they heard it the question was do we
have to write centimeters every single
time like it's a little bit tiresome
right now I'll show you I'll tell you
the reason why I wrote centimeters every
time the reason is I'm really forgetful
and when I don't write centimeters early
on I like forget about it and then I'm
just I'm so happy I got the right number
that I then move on so I'm going to
encourage you to put the lengths in if
you don't want to write centimeters
every single time probably the best way
to write this is to have all of the
numbers and then say hey you know what
all of them they're all centimeters
because at least that way you've got the
unit's I know a lot of people are just
going to do this they're just going to
put the numbers and then do some
calculations and then magically
centimeters will appear at the bottom if
you do that I can't stop you but I feel
like it's number
putting yourself in the at the mercy of
your own memory like are you gonna
remember to do at the end and number two
it's just kind of weird that centimeters
appear like who plays Pokemon here's a
big one right you know it's like a wild
centimeters appeared like what is that
about like that just seems strange that
appears out of nowhere okay